well all the ideas out there are big
ideas all of those things that are
getting made are
are
more interesting than i am not realizing
that
you are a wealth of story i am a wealth
of story and i just have to dig deep
enough to figure out what story do i
want to tell
what's the difference between helping
other people achieve their dreams
and pursuing your own dreams
well i think that
for sure pursuing my own dreams was
scarier it's a lot easier to help
somebody else
but i've often said that
helping someone achieve their dreams is
it's like there's like a crack high i've
never done crack but i imagine it's like
the crack high that
that you would get just because
um
it is
truly intoxicating
and um
and i've been in that
that business that world for a long time
you know as a as an executive you're
constantly you're green lighting things
or you're you know
pushing something forward or you're
introducing someone to some some key
relationship
um or you're hiring a staff for a show
or a director
and making that phone call
is
is an amazing phone call i remember when
i when i uh we were picking up living
single and uh and i happened to be at
home and my boss at the time tom noonan
said hey you can make this phone call he
says this is your show you can make this
phone call and i
called yvette lee bowser and um
and uh and i screamed in her ear and it
was such a high-pitched scream because i
was so excited and uh and there was this
sort of pause on the other end of the
call and she's like
i didn't hear a thing you just said
i was because i was so excited
so it's um
it's a really wonderful feeling to be
able to support some i think it's easy
for me because
you know there are i think there may be
the difference between
when someone is is just starting out
particularly and i've you know obviously
worked with auto writers and directors
who are just emerging
um what they need most besides the
acknowledgement the encouragement
and the just the you know the general
support of helping
shape a piece of material
is they really need those connections
and i've got a lot of connections and so
making those phone calls is not hard for
me and that's part of it and what i find
the difference is between people who
are
just emerging and struggling and the
people who are are really firing on all
cylinders is sometimes their network
let's just say everything equal
the materials all equal and they're
great people everywhere which i do find
they're great people everywhere
the people who are connected and the
people who are are we are able to create
relationships for
those relationships exponentially just
you know just it explode
and um and so i just lend my at this
point
for many of those i just led my
connections and that's the difference
between
you know someone getting moving forward
and someone not getting moving forward
oftentimes
so um so that part's easy for for myself
it's harder because i sit there and i'm
wallowing in my own material right and
sometimes you're trying to figure out
well what do you do next and how do you
navigate you're trying to put your
business hat on and go well if i work on
this it's gonna take me away from that
so what am i gonna do and what's the
material i'm putting out in the
marketplace and then i have to really
tap into my own
personal
mishigos about well what's my stuff that
i want to
you know what do i want to say and who
do i want to be
and that takes a lot of
work emotional work that making a phone
call does not
does not tax my brain
but doing my own personal work is uh is
hard so i do think you know
focusing on myself has been
a little bit of a challenge but
i think it's
i think it's also time right
do you think that maybe
being conditioned to feel guilty for
wanting to do something on your own i
mean you know there's a there's an air
of selfishness with any creative pursuit
where it seems like oh well it's one of
these sort of you know artists that
they're just going to disregard
everything and and go off and and create
is there is there some kind of a stigma
with wanting to
do your own thing creatively
i don't know i think for me i'm at this
place in my life where i'm i've got an
empty nest and even if my kids are here
they're adult kids so
they know that if i'm gonna lock myself
away that it's okay
i think it gets a little harder with my
mother who wants to go to costco every
week and i'm like we just go to costco
and costco now it used to be like going
to costco with mom was a you know you're
in and out in 45 minutes and you know
you leave with a bunch of stuff and now
she likes to linger
and when i when she asks me if she wants
if i want to go to costco with her the
guilt that i feel about
now i really don't want to spend two
hours in costco that's and it seems
trivial but i think that's indicative of
when someone else is asking for your
time and when that person is really
important to you and you want to give
that time but you don't always want to
give that time all the time
then yeah you have to make some choices
sometimes that family you know
dinner
is like the last thing you want to do
so you have to negotiate
it's important to negotiate your family
time for sure
they've got great
samples they do have great samples
although
they're not always vegetarian samples
and that's my issue yeah sure sure yeah
and from being on the other end of doing
uh samples in the past you meet people
that they want to talk to you and that's
their only outlet right there and and
could be vice versa i know it's mutual
but i know you had written some um posts
about riding the bus yes and and some of
the interesting people that you had met
and it's the same for probably doing
some of these samples and and some of
the people you encounter in the grocery
store it's that was one of the best
you know i think coveted
shut down my bus riding quite
considerably
but from 2015 to 2020 i rode the bus
exclusively and and very rarely was i
in a car
and it was the best
most
i don't know
um relaxing
time you would not think that it would
be but i think you know if you're
obviously if you're stressed for time um
and there was one day that i was trying
to do it going to uh getting to the
airport to go to india and i was
stressed like crazy because it was a bus
ride that took way longer than it should
have but for the most part i met so many
amazing people i learned about my town
my city
i i really got a chance to
engage with a lot of the world in a way
that i hadn't in a really long time and
it's a weird thing to say because in you
know new york you're always in public
transportation in la
you're not you're usually in a car
but it was
it was a pretty
um
magical kind of you know five years
that i i do look forward to
and i'm not i'm a talker anyway so i
will i will chat people up at the drop
of a hat
so just put me in a place where there's
more people
and i'll start talking
why wasn't it okay for you to pursue
your writing dreams when you were a
little bit younger
well
uh
when i was coming out of college
my stepdad who has passed away just
before covent
we uh we had a very interesting
conversation again i remember exactly
where we had this conversation it was on
the back
stoop of his
house
and um
he wanted me to have a real job and he
was concerned he was concerned that i
wasn't going to be able to make
a living in the industry
and
so he had recommended that i
take a secretarial job working for
a company downtown i think it was an
interior design company
couldn't have been farther from who i
was personally because i may i have
terrible tastes in decorating
and um
and i know where it came from it came
from his fear that you know that i
needed to have some some means of
support
and he had grown up in the depression
and his father was i believe his father
was a dentist and he he ended up going
into the dental field he was a dentist
but what he really wanted to be was a
writer
and he'd written some books along the
way he'd written them about dentistry
um if you want to buy one j.w friedman i
don't can look him up
but
but he had never really
ventured out
and and took it seriously or took
himself seriously and the short stories
that he wrote were just beautiful
and i considered at one point making one
of them into a short film but it's just
just beautiful work
and then he decided he'd had this this
idea
sort of locked away inside of him for
years and he finally wrote it in his 70s
and it's a book out there um
i don't i don't even know where you can
find it now but um
i think it's called the seventh
millennium and it's uh you know it's
it's not my cup of tea but it's it's
certainly
everything it's a it's it's underneath
it's about his first marriage and
there's like a lot of themes that come
up for him and it was his magnum opus it
was his thing that he wanted to put out
there
and and he wrote this one little book
and uh and then talked about it for the
next 20 years
and i think his concern was that
i think it was the real fear that i
think a lot of parents have about their
kids are they going to make it or are
they not going to be able to make this
happen for themselves
so
so that coupled with you know the the
parental pressure from him on the other
hand my mom's going go for it do
whatever you want it's okay
um but that combined with i needed to
make real money
and the job that i had at the time
you know when i was a writer's assistant
was probably barely making you know rent
um but again it's trying to figure out
well what's the trajectory and how can
you pursue it and when you don't see
people who are doing it
and you don't see that there's a pathway
and and i was writing on a show
uh a writer's assistant on a show where
it was two latino leads and an entirely
white
male writers room
and even that's even in my own you know
so basically my own backyard and i can't
seem to figure out and navigate how to
do how to get in there
i think that there's uh
there's societal things that happen
where you know and i think and i don't
think that this is unusual i think if
you look back and and hear a lot of
stories from a lot of people around that
time and even before it was a hard
business to break into it still is a
hard business to break into and when
you're a woman of color
you know you've got a couple of
you know um
you know the pathways were just not
plentiful
so i think that if i
if i had been
i don't know that i knew i don't think i
had any other options i don't think i
was
missing anything
i think i was in the
i was doing the right things i was
writing the scripts i was working on my
craft
i do think that there was a frustration
at a certain point where i did stop
writing because it was just too painful
but i think i also got in my own head
and i think if i had
if i was going to give anybody
some
advice now
or even if i was going to talk to myself
you know back in the 80s i would have
said just keep writing and i think i
also didn't understand at the time
that
i had something to say i think i was
really
probably putting up a roadblock because
i thought
well all the ideas out there are big
ideas all of those things that are
getting made are
are
more interesting than i am not realizing
that
you are a wealth of story i am a wealth
of story and i just have to dig deep
enough to figure out what story do i
want to tell i could tell a story about
riding on the bus and it could be an
emotional heartfelt amazing story i at
the time probably would not have
recognized that
but it took me a long time and a pathway
through
the executive ranks in order to get to
the other side and go oh yeah there's
value in in just about everything